creating images that are more than good
enough is what this case study is about
this happened quite a while ago about
can't believe it's 20 years ago in this
lab this is the image that the
researchers came up with on their own
you're seeing a surface that has etched
out hydrophobic lines and so when you
drop water on the surface the water
stops at these hydrophobic lines this
measures a across about four millimeters
so these are drops of water that are
taking on the shape of the hydrophobic
lines and this is how it was used in the
article that was accepted I luckily came
across it because this sort of started
my whole career 20 years ago in science
imaging what I did with this image as
you've seen before is I asked them to
please make a triangle so I could start
working a little bit with this and I
dropped some water on that triangle also
etched out here as you remember I made
the picture with direct lighting here i
diffuse the lighting and I was playing
around a little more another chip was
etched out as well and I started using
fluorescing material to drop on the chip
this gold it's called a self-assembled
monolayers in this image I'd I wanted to
show a sense of scale so I used the
syringe with which I dropped the water
on the surface just to give you a sense
of scale finally getting around to
submitting for a cover design I asked
the researchers could you please at
least give me a grid of the etched lines
so I could then drop onto the grid
fluorescing green water and fluorescing
blue water and you could actually see
the edge to Mark's creating the
hydrophobic lines I didn't like seeing
too much those lines were in the way so
just moving the camera ever so slightly
gave me a cleaner image and again I was
imagining the journals logo at the top
what was really important was that the
editors felt that the way I photographed
it was miss informational that is you're
seeing two tones of green and two tones
of blue and that was miscommunication
for them it turns out that's really the
way it was but in the end what we did
decide to do was give them a simplified
version where I focused in tightly onto
the square drops of water as we call
them they're colored water with
fluorescing dyes each square is about
four millimeters across and it was a
simplified image as what we strive for
and in the end we were lucky and it did
get the cover